لقد دخلنا غزة منذ ما يقرب من ثلاثة أشهر، معظمنا
كنا نظن أن ثلاثة أشهر كانت فترة طويلة، ولا
وربما لا نكون حتى قد قطعنا نصف الطريق
وهكذا اتضح أن حماس تعرف كيف تقاتل
وتيهال يعرف كيف يقاتل، وتيهال يستطيع الفوز
نفس الشيء ولكن بجهود أكبر بكثير من
أن المواطن الذي يقوم به المدني يتم تصلب
المواقف في الرحلة والعطاء للصفقة تتخطف وتقول لو
لا يوجد وقف للقتال، ولا يوجد حاليا ما يمكن مناقشته
تذهب إلى الشواطئ لقضاء عطلة لمدة أسبوع
أسبوعين، ثلاثة، سنتسلق الشواطئ
لقد أظهرنا استعدادنا لدفع أثمان باهظة ل
للعودة إلى الشواطئ، أعتقد أن هناك براءة بحرية
خطوة الحكومة الصحيحة ونحن مستعدون للقيام بها
بل هو أيضا الآن لتشكيل القتال للافراج
المختطفون على استعداد لدفع أسعار خاصة ل
إن إطلاق سراح الرهائن أمر مهم بالنسبة لنا
صحيح أن لها أسعارها أيضًا، لكن في النهاية
أثبت Zel قدرته حتى بعد توقف
المضي قدما للاستيلاء على المزيد من الأراضي والوصول إلى الأهداف
إنها ليست مثالية وأعتقد أنها في الوضع الحالي
سنجعل المصداقية تبني الثقة عندما لا يكون هناك أي منها
الموثوقية ولا يهم ما هي الأسباب والعكس هو الصحيح
نحن
في الأساس أعظم قوة جيش
من الحكومة هي ثقة الجمهور الذي تحدثنا عنه
المصداقية التي يظهرها الجيش في التحقيق مع المختطفين
مصداقية قول حتى أسوأ الأشياء
الجمهور ليس غبيًا، إنه ليس صدر هذا جلين
يتعلق الأمر بحقيقة أننا اعتقدنا أن قصة الآن يجب أن تظل قائمة
تقف غلاند وتقول إن سيمار تسمع الطائرات
الآن سوف يسمع قصب النفق الذي كشفوه
في الأسبوع الماضي أخذوا جميع الصحفيين
في شمال الشريط لرؤيتها هو الذي يأتي بشكل جيد للغاية
وبالقرب من معبر إيرز يوجد نفق به أيضًا شاهد قبر
يقولون أنهم يعرفون الرتبة، ولكني أريدها
اسأل فقط كمتحدث لأنه كان هناك أيضًا انتقادات لذلك
يقدم شاتزال إزاحة الستار عن المنارة برقم 3 ثم كان هناك أيضًا
تركت المراجعات أنها تسربت من الخزانة التي أمامي
فهذا حرام ولكن جوهر الأشياء هو هذا
لماذا تقدمونه كنوع من الإنجاز؟
هل تعلم عنها لا أعرف الترتيب
كما ينبغي أن تكون العثرات واضحة التدمير أو السحق
القدرات العسكرية والسيطرة على حركة حماس والمختطفين
ويقفون في نفس المكان من حيث أولوية المختطفين
الوقوف في المقدمة من حيث الأولويات
بعد السنوار ومران عيسى أو أو بيش محمد
الصفحة يمكن مطاردة المختطفين حتى خلال عام واحد
قد لا تكون هذه على قيد الحياة إذا لم تكن كذلك
سننتهز كل فرصة لإخراجها لك في أي لحظة
هناك فرصة لمدة ثلاثة أسابيع، ونحن على وشك الانتهاء
سوف تمر ثلاثة أشهر عندما تأتي الأسابيع الثلاثة
هذه إذا أخذنا استراحة بعد ثلاثة أشهر
أسبوعين أو ثلاثة أسابيع وسنحضر المزيد
الشواطئ قرار معقول تماما، صحيح أنه لا يوجد شيء منها
التعامل مع الوضع